megan is with us in San Antonio Texas hi
Megan welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
how are you better than I deserve
what's up at the beginning of the year
my husband turns me on to you because he
listens to a lot of talk radio and it
took me a minute to kind of get into
listening to you as well but now I'm the
one that's all wanting to do it and he's
the one that's trying to hesitant on
taking the steps on losing Fulmer he
seems to be kind of scatterbrained he
wants to do everything that works and I
can't seem to get him to focus on doing
one thing at a time and it's making him
very discouraged okay so what is it
you're trying to do one thing at a time
well I can't even get him to focus on
getting baby stuff one which is just her
thousand dollar emergency fund he's
wanting to put money away towards the
emergency phone as well as as well as
put money towards our debt and okay so
you only one is he got motivated about
money in general and then you learned
you went and learned our system and you
like our system and he doesn't
understand it yet correct or has decided
he or does decided he wants his own
system yeah he's just kind of wanting to
do everything all at once if you don't
get it done faster yeah that's a pretty
typical thing we like to do everything
it wants all of us we live in a
microwave culture but the problem is
that doesn't work with money as you have
already figured out you're a very
systematic person in all of your life
aren't you yes I try to be yeah that's
good that's good in me too my brain kind
of works that way that's how I
recognized it but there's a while people
and there's now people kind of thing and
so are not now people or whatever so the
good news is you both think something
needs to happen the only thing you
disagree on is how it needs to happen
and how fast it needs to happen
so that's better than that's better than
one of you that doesn't care right at
least you both care so that's a really
really good start and so I think what
you got to do is I have learned in my 37
years of marriage that I as a male I am
thick I do not hear what my wife says
often and she has to really work to make
sure to get my attention if she talks at
me while there's 17 other things going
on I don't hear squat and unless she
makes a really decisive she thinks she
said something to me that's really
important and there's four other things
going on and I didn't even hear her and
that's what you're doing here you're
doing a drive-by shooting okay instead
what I want you to do is I want you to
turn off the television not know there's
no food at the table and the kids if
there are any errors sleep and the dogs
in the freaking garage and it's just the
two of you and you sit down kneecap to
kneecap and look in his eyes and say we
have to talk this is a big deal then
maybe he'll start to hear you because
guys can do one thing at a time ladies
can do six things at a time we can't
hear you unless you hit us about the
head okay and so that's all it is this
is a good man he cares he actually cares
about this subject which is great we
don't have to motivate him we just got
to direct his motivation this is awesome
and so we've got to talk you told me
listen this Dave guy he's actually
making sense you're running around like
a chicken with your head cut off I want
us to try to do this system because his
system works ours sucks
I don't look at him in his face and say
this and I don't care what your opinion
is because your opinion is what got us
here okay so we need to do something
different right you can't keep doing the
same thing over and over again and
expect a different result right okay
some time for new recipe and so oh this
is a good man all you other speak man
to him not woman to him and that means
real clear real direct real quiet no
interferences because he needs to hear
on a scale of 1 to 10 this is a 10 for
you because he loves his wife and if
it's a big deal this say you doing this
would be like you've given me a diamond
you're doing this would be like taking
me to Aruba it would be that kind of a
thing for you to do this with me he'll
hear that he kids I want y'all been
married five years
I don't see headaches now so so what's
the coolest thing he ever bought for you
or did for you that made you just light
up and he knew he lit you up cooking on
a little shopping spree I James Avery
there you go just bring that up go this
doing this would be better than that
little shopping spree from me that's how
much it would mean to me because I think
we'll change our lives together and I
think we'll get to do shopping sprees or
whatever we want to do if we go do this
and get our act together okay does that
make sense to you okay now I'm gonna be
in San Antonio this fall with Chris
Hogan on November the 15th doing one of
our smart money events I'm going to give
you two tickets by the time you get
there this fall those two tickets are
for you to come to this event and
celebrate how much you've been winning
already before you get there because I'm
also going to put the two of you in
Financial Peace University because
between now and this fall you guys are
going to get your crap together hold on
I'm gonna have Kelly pickups and you
just got to communicate to him where he
hears you and we just do not hear I mean
Sharon and I we have to I have to I have
to make sometimes I'll catch her doing
that to me and I have to stop and I just
had to turn lay the phone down turn the
TV off clear that clear out whatever
distractions there are because I I'm now
some of you guys maybe you don't agree
with me and some of you don't like
generalities and all that you can kiss
my butt okay
there's generalities they're just true
and guys can hear one thing at a time
ladies have the ability to multitask
tons of studies that show that by the
way which is an advantage for the female
of the species but it's a disadvantage
to males when we're trying to actually
listen to you because we don't hear you
you know these we don't get subtleties
ladies get nuanced guys don't get nuance
much you just kind of have to get right
in the face and go this is the way it is
you know and then we hear it I hear it
clear and I love you I want to do stuff
for you but not when I get these vague
drive-by shootings I don't have any idea
what that means from a communication
standpoint it's a disaster the does
communication did not occur because I
did not hear you you know it doesn't
work so that's a deal I hope that helps
and those of you that are mad about the
battle of the sexes or whatever it is
you're mad about all the time you can
just take that to Twitter and I don't
even read it that much anymore anyways I
don't really care what you think so
another troll to delete today
delete delete oh it's not trolling its
criticism good delete delete delete this
is called the Dave Ramsey show you know
why this is Dave Ramsey's opinion that's
why we call it that how many wanst is
that this is the Dave Ramsey show